change lives change organizations change
the world the slogan of this school and
a testament to how much this university
loves change so much so they have to
tell the sale or change three times in
the same slogan is if you're gonna
forget it's an important thing and in
many ways we're all here because we want
to be those change agents I know I do
because I'm a product of that change
twenty years ago I was living in broken
homes to broken home I couldn't eat
every day I'd terrible grades and adults
would tell me things like college a
career standing on stage delivering a
speech or not for people like you and to
them I say look at me now is it is
amazing to be here to talk in front of
all of you and I would have never
dreamed it to be someone who couldn't
change himself to someone who can now
change lives change organizations and
change the world and that's what I stay
out to do my first year I wanted to
bring what I thought was the secret
sauce to my success my change and bring
it to places in the world that didn't
have it and so what I did was I said it
was education I did my research I looked
all around the world I found the place
in northeast India called West Bengal
where the average income of families is
600 a year where nobody gets past the
eighth grade and the average life
expectancy is 32 32 and I said the
biggest problem they have is education
so I think I did what anyone would do I
bought that 50 seater bus I tore it
apart I put a classroom inside of it and
I drove it into the jungles of west
bengal and started to teach out of it
but they teach you in strategy right and
so I want to first though before I
started teaching get the permission of
the village leadership and so the pilot
village i worked in teppan Tardos a man
named Cole I explained to him what I was
doing and he said wait let me show you
something he took me outside of his
house to the center of the village
there's this bronze statue
and you said a villager made this
because this is what we are told
education is and it's an image i think
that's familiar to a lot of us it's the
evolution of man you know that image
that we all start out as primates and we
slowly evolved to upright man make sense
rights progress of course it's education
but the funny thing about what this
sculptor did in this village was the
added a step to say where humankind was
going where superior human beings were
going to be and Beyond upright man it's
hunched over typing away the computer at
the IT job right so y'all you very
laughing like when was the last time
you're in a library looking at a guy
making Excel she knows like yep evolved
guy right that's superior right there
and as much as it's funny the thing
about this village is they're dead
serious and so clost callow start to
explain to me this is what we're told i
T is our salvation and you're not the
first person to come and try and provide
us education in fact so many have before
but they always get it wrong because
they never answer the question what
happens after the kids get educated
where did they go everyone is telling us
i T is the solution but in a 50
kilometer radius around this village
there's not a single IT resource
available and so I asked him is there
any cases have anybody made it before
and he said one and I looked at that and
I know is out of desperation and sadness
but I heard as inspirational one well
let's figure out what this kid did
everything and make sure everyone knows
that and then this problem will be
solved and so luckily his parents were
in this village of teppan car and I went
to interview them I said what did your
son do I wanna know everything what does
he study how did he study and his father
looked at me he said I don't know and
not only that but he said I'm not
supposed to know because my son is now
in a better place and I'm a craftsman
and I'm proud of it and that's what
supporting my family and generations
before me but it doesn't make any money
today and people are telling us it
doesn't so anything I want to keep my
son here to teach them my ways to teach
him the heritage of our family it's only
going to hold him back
and so the best thing I can do for him
is to let him go and when I heard that
it hurt a lot and I didn't understand
why because I don't even know this kid
but what I do know is he's a role model
he's what everyone should be he is smart
he's talented he's driven he made it
everyone should be like him and why I
couldn't figure it out until I realized
that kids me because 30 years ago I
didn't grow up in rural India but my
village was China and at that time my
parents why desperately to get out
because they went through the history of
terrible things happening and they were
lucky enough to be one of the ones to
set foot in America and start anew in
the land of prosperity and the first
thing they wanted was they want to give
birth to a child so he can live up in
this prosperity and that was me but
shortly after I was born they had to go
back to China for a variety of reasons
and so they were left with the tough
decision of either keeping the family
together but take me back to a country
that will forever him in my potential or
to keep me with unlimited potential but
to rip away the family and just like
that family and tap and tar my parents
chose prosperity as much as it hurts to
not be around them to never know if
you're going to see them again in some
ways they were right in that decision
right I'm standing here when I said look
at me now everyone applauded that can be
this person who changes lives changed
organizations and changes the world but
to get there I had to change my friends
change my family and change my home over
and over again and be proud of it
because that's change now imagine if
that were the slogan of this school
Stanford University change your friends
change your family change your home
right I mean I didn't get the best rates
and marketing but i can tell you not
inspiration all right but that's what
happened and I don't say that because I
want to change the slogan of this school
it's done wonders it's amazing slogan
but why do propose is a slogan for our
lives especially as we leave this school
and get out there to pursue our careers
to not always be so obsessed with change
to be disruptive but to take on the
challenge of simply to keep to keep your
friends to keep your family and to keep
your home thank you